so
last week i give a fire safety talk
and nobody paid any attention it's my
own fault for using powerpoint
powerpoint is boring people learn in
lots of different ways
but experience is the best teacher
today smoking is gonna save lives
does anyone smell anything smoky did you
bring your jerky in again
oh my god uh oh my god fire
oh fire oh my goodness what's the
procedure what do we do people
are dead oh how did that happen it's out
in the hall
no we don't know that the smoke could be
coming through an air duct oh my god
okay it's happening everybody stay calm
what's the procedure everyone what's the
procedure
calm down no no michael no touch the
handle if it's hot there could be a fire
in the hallway
what does warm mean oh my gosh not a
viable option
what next don't shock the other door oh
here's the door
check that one out how's the handle it's
warm okay go to the bathroom
oh another option oh geez i'm getting a
tunnel
on everyone no i forgot my purse leave
it woman get out of the way go go go
things can be replaced phyllis
people human lives however can
ah my hand that's hot yeah this one's
hot too
okay we're trapped everyone for himself
okay let's go
a rag a damp rag perhaps let's remember
those procedures what are the options
that's the wrong way we've already tried
that remember your exit points exit
points
people what's next um stay alive i'm
getting help pull me up
you're too heavy i only weigh 82 pounds
save it
how about 911
[Music]
what do we do use this surge of fear and
adrenaline to sharpen your decision
making okay i am not dying here come on
oh my god
oh
[Applause]
attention employees of dunder mifflin
this has been a test of our emergency
preparedness
there is no fire it was only a
simulation what
fire not real this was merely a training
exercise
so what have we learned oh
come on it's not real stanley don't have
a heart attack no no no no no you will
not die
staley stanley you will not die stanley
stanley barack is president you are
black
sadly i'm going to give him mouth about
no don't give him out the mouth for this
you're going to swallow his tongue open
she asked me the whole thing and i
didn't even do it what baby
i'm back thank you so wow ah
why are you naked oh well because of
what you said we're getting back
together
no we're not yes we are you should have
heard the super sexy stuff she was
saying to me
i said hey andy it's ann can we talk at
my house
how you said it you were like hey andy
it's anne can you
talk at my house oh my god you're such a
baby
oh literally big naked baby put clothes
on
you know what i should have seen this
coming has he showed up naked before
oh yeah anniversaries birthdays holidays
good luck where are you hey aunt just
none of your clothes fit me so putting
an apron over the front step
good news i was able to obtain eleanor
shellstrop's file
is it actually a cactus i don't
understand i want to see the file for
eleanor shellstrop is that what you have
or do you have a cactus i have the file
you're sure you have the file and
and not a cactus that is correct i have
eleanor shellstrop's file i do not have
a cactus
excellent please give me the file here
you go
thank you janet you're welcome i'm like
an elephant okay if i walk into a room
it's like okay he's in there
magic time
[Applause]
oh my god
you're welcome
put this music down
[Music]
frankly i pity the lot of you you look
out there and see a problem
i look out there and see an opportunity
i'm gonna slide on that slippery floor
all the way from holt's office
to the elevator you're gonna do the fbp
that's right rosa
i'm doing the full bullpen
[Music]
here we go
[Music]
is
[Music]
the full bullpen there he is
and he's got the humans within all right
let's just go back up here what do we do
this
how far away is the sun uh 93 million
miles
yeah and the diameter of the sun is 870
thousand miles which makes it 109 times
wider than the earth
and 333 thousand times heavier than the
earth shut up about the sun
shut up about the sun i'll make some
coffee
oh i i really shouldn't helen
what's one cup oh god that smells good
high fives and low fives are better than
no fives
if somebody calls you a wet blanket ask
them how they'd like it in a
desert if they saw you there are you
getting this yes yes
more more if you step on a berry you
just made some jam
i think i need more coffee jack
if you pass gas when you're leaving a
room it's called a toodaloo
is that the first half of something if
you spill your milk it's just a paper
towel getting a promotion
oh my god here's a good one jack if you
escape the womb you can escape anything
one last thought before we open that
this is going to be a very good year
very good
jan is at home jim is back my protege
ryan is a corporate
good stuff um andy and dwight
are rocking the sales team i feel very
[Music]
blessed
you